from the swashbuckling sorrow to the
gunslinger mariachi Antonio Banderas has
been a household name for decades he
remained a constant on our screens over
the years reprising the role of sorrow
and joining big-budget franchises in
track and spy kids but recently his
status is a genuine a list of has come
into question
we don't really hear much from Banderas
nowadays and here's why
typecast although Banderas took on some
pretty varied roles in his early acting
days in Spain his transition to
Hollywood almost immediately
pigeon-holed him as the Latin Lover with
the sensual voice even his action scenes
feel like he might just start getting
sexy at any minute
well that not mine at all no matter how
much makeup you put on his face or how
many things are exploding Antonio
Banderas is never more than one tango
away from taking you to bed it's a tag
that's followed him his entire career
even though he's often tried to shake
the typecasting with movies like
assassins the 13th warrior and 2011 the
skin I live in in which he played a
deranged search
unfortunately critics haven't been
particularly kind to Banderas enslaves
work of the last 10 Antonio Banderas
movies reviewed on Rotten Tomatoes Age
of them have scores of less than 50% in
2014 he turned up in the Expendables 3
looking to work these action chops
[Music]
but the film was bashed by critics and
the verdict was just as bad when
Banderas took on the lead role in
automata later that year in their review
of the apocalyptic sci-fi film The Wrap
said that Banderas was all wrong to the
part criticizing him for being shoddy
where he should be Stern confused where
you should be glued in franchise player
when Antonio Banderas signed on to play
Puss in Boots in track 2 and 2004 he
probably had no idea how popular the
character would become he showed up
again in two more Shrek sequels and no
less than five animated specials not to
mention his own spin-off prequel in 2011
it grossed over half a billion dollars
as the worldwide box office but
eventually the franchise was bound to
run out of steam
similarly Spy Kids finally fizzled and
Robert Rodriguez's Mexico trilogy
reached its conclusion with Once Upon a
Time in Mexico Antonio Banderas has
plenty of other solid film credits but
for nearly a decade he's acting work
rested heavily on franchises that
ultimately reached their end but no
matter what Banderas always has a
fallback you can make anything sound
sexy really okay the dark side gigs
since 1997 Antonio Banderas has been
creating his own line of men's
fragrances alongside Spanish fashion and
cosmetics giant pooch in 2015 Banderas
also announced that he had signed off as
a student at the famous London fashion
school at Central Saint Martin's he told
the school publication I'm going to
continue doing movies and producing and
I want to direct more but there were
other things in my life that I was
interested in what were those things if
you guest tapes you be yeah you'd be
right Antonio Banderas wants to make
cakes
on top of these fragrance and fashion
side gigs Banderas is also a United
Nations Development Programme Goodwill
Ambassador and he has his own foundation
cares and favors which provides support
to cancer patients in other words we
don't see him so much anymore because
he's super busy with his commitments
away from Hollywood family time in 2014
Melanie Griffith and Antonio Banderas
released a joint statement confirming
there were bringing they're near two
decades of marriage to a close Pandarus
saw this as an opportunity to turn over
a new leaf and have been busy spending
more time with his family
he told me news my life changed very
much during the last two years
personally the possibility of
reinventing myself was there and so I
said probably this is the moment that I
can do this
Ben Darras also revealed that both his
stepdaughter Dakota Johnson and his
biological daughter Stella helped him
get through the person I told my kids
sometimes but in fact the reality is I
learned from them more they were not
very obedient
but I learned from them leaving
Hollywood in 2015 Banderas left the
bright lights of Hollywood for the UK
countryside he currently lives with his
dutch girlfriend Nicole Campbell in the
TaylorMade eco mansion that set him back
more than three million dollars looking
back it's hardly a surprised that
Banderas chose to leave the states as a
few years earlier he and his then wife
Melanie Griffith tried to buy an
apartment in world-famous New York
apartment building the Dakota only to be
turned away because Ben Darras was
Hispanic according to a lawsuit the suit
suggested that the board made cool jokes
about Banderas upon receiving his
application claiming he wanted a
first-floor apartment so it would be
easier to buy drugs of the stream health
concerns in January 2017
Pandarus was rushed to a hospital near
his home in England after suffering
agonizing pain in his chest during the
workout the spanish star initially
dismissed the incident as an episode and
tweeted a photo of himself and
girlfriend nicole campbell with the
caption enjoying nature after a little
startled he later confirmed that it was
in
a heart attack and that get to undergo
the knife to fix the problem it was a
benign attack it hasn't caused any
permanent damage and now I'm in a
recovery period it's something that
happens every day to a lot of people I
did hide it but I didn't want it to
receive more importance than those
suffered by other people well that's
great news studio execs may think twice
before casting him in long term roles
which is a real shame for both the actor
and he stands alike what's next
one reason that Banderas chose to move
out of the spotlight was to focus on his
writing he told The Sunday Times I'm not
a party person anymore so at this pace
and pinch the write and really get
inside my own head and working on
several scripts whether any of the
screenplay she's currently writing will
come to fruition is anyone's guess but
what we do know is that Banderas hasn't
given up the ghost on acting quite yet
he'll star alongside Adrien Brody and
John Malkovich tinner Reservoir Dogs
style thriller called Unchained playing
an aging rock star in the action comedy
salty and headlining the upcoming
revenge thriller stoic you might have
been out of the picture for a while
but Ben Darras looks like he has enough
left in the tank for a few more roles of
the day and if that doesn't work there's
always Kate thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
you